it's going pretty good I'm not gonna get
soaked you know why cuz I'm gonna take a
raft that means I'm not gonna be in the
water I'll be good
[Music]
do you hear that it is pouring out there
just check this out look at that I don't
have shoes okay okay it was it's been a
rainy day it's been a it's been a gloomy
rainy day and I'm like dude all I want
is a nice hot sandwich and a cup of soup
from Porter and I ordered it about 20
minutes ago and I was just about to go
pick it up I come out and literally that
the entire street is flooded the entire
street come all the way here all the way
down there I can't even get to my car
even if I wanted to because there's so
much rain and even if I did get to my
car and I tried to move it I lose my
parking spot because parking down here
yeah it's nuts
it is sucks so first we have an old raft
which is gonna get soaked you need it
all eat it there I'm not gonna get
soaked you know why cuz I'm gonna take a
raft that means I'm not gonna be in the
water all I need is a rain jacket I'll
be good friend and install an umbrella
we have an umbrella
as a Minnesotan we come from the land of
10,000 lakes and you got to think
outside the box you know you never miss
an opportunity to utilize water to your
advantage
water can be a very dry form of
transportation if you use it correctly
what is going on there was not remotely
this amount of water when we came in
today it's this has all been since this
morning
aren't you ready I got a hood this is an
all-weather rain jacket I'm just gonna
hop in this boat and we'll be on our way
that's the worst part that's the part
that's unfort about this is where it all
starts and finishes take it to see mr.
Murdock
[Music]
do that fluently
pretty good guard cars behind me
[Music]
pocket
as he kind of coming get out of the way
over here
how's it going lawyer dude oh it's going
we're just talking about how weird it is
it like we did the Logan Paul interview
we basically
became one with the flat earthers and
then a day later it's being reported on
Logan Paul reveals how Shane Dawson
inspired his new video the vlogger hit
up chord or digital to get visual
effects for his upcoming flat earth
documentary and the guys agreed to help
Logan out is he agreed to be on their
podcast I was like kicking a beehive
completely expecting it honestly but
there was one criticism that I didn't
want to address which was huge guys
shouldn't have even given him a platform
to have spout his crazy views or
whatever they do take issue with that
because we didn't give him a platform
there's the directed conversation
directed by me and Clint so we were the
ones controlling the conversation not
Logan Paul
it's our platform that's it one of the
coolest things that came out of this was
actually people commenting that you know
they listened to the podcast they didn't
become fans of Logan Paul and that's
totally fine you don't have to like
Logan Paul the cool thing was that
people were now basing that on actual
first-hand experience with what he had
to say rather than just listening to
some tabloid or drama hit piece looking
to get views like that stuff isn't
healthy for actual discourse like no it
just made me happy okay we had so many
people in our audience that were like
humans about it mature about it I was
going through all the comments yeah it's
like a maturity thing you guys are like
still don't agree with your viewpoints
and so don't agree with what you do
things but I'm not like hating thank you
guys for listening I hope you two get
more controversial people not more
controversial than o de Paul but just
more people that are controversial on
the podcast not once again to give them
a platform but it's fascinating to talk
to those people you know movies are
boring if there's no villains and then
we learn from their journey just so much
if you learn for everybody else's all in
all I thought was pretty neat actually
ow
I'll never let go you gotta think
outside the box
you know you never missed an opportunity
to utilize water to your advantage
[Music]
I think that went pretty well I mean I'm
here what's the damage man you look
pretty soaked to me
it's like regular you know a little bit
of rain the water smells like eggs
it's in the old get my sandwich hope
it's still hot when I get there
where's my phone you gotta sweat jacket
to go back cuddle up with a nice cup of
soup delicious thank you
your soap is your sandwich wet sandwich
don't open that up you're gonna get all
the heat out of there still warm
friends got damn it son it's still war
no I'm gonna go close there and eat this
son so let me get out of these Wow you
could outside Crescent kick someone like
looks like without them knowing
stay with me here it is still still
there but your your actual leg like your
pant leg is there but your foot comes
out and it looks like you just retained
it all times like guy should get water
all over the floor you know why cuz I'm
gonna take a raft that means I'm not
gonna be in the water I'll be good
things got yeah I got a little bit more
wet than I had expected
yeah I mean I think give it everything I
think that went couldn't have gone
better
subscribe chances are you're a fan of
Freddie Wong I know I certainly am
basically grew up together on YouTube
huh those were the days
birdy is a guest on the corridor castes
go over there and take a look it's a
good conversation really funny we ask
them a lot of good questions that you
probably would like to hear the answers
to link in the description or maybe on
screen right now who knows boy it's cold
out
Carter cast go subscribe